gourmandise et ateliers créatifs le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville de magny les
hameaux s'est transformé en grande fête
un moyen de célébrer noël avant l'heure
en famille nous avons fait maquillage on
a fait fabrication de cartes avec des
gommettes océan bas de la maison c'est
convivial c'est génial pour les enfants
et ils font plein d'activités on vient
quasiment tous les temps c'est le c'est
un petit peu le démarrage des festivités
un goûter géant et des animations
organisées par la ville cet événement
est devenu incontournable
les gens viennent vraiment d'année en
année avec les enfants avec les petits
enfants ont réuni ici
plusieurs milliers de personnes pendant
tout l'après midi
c'est noël les fêtes de fin d'année
avant l'heure tout simplement est
accessible à tout le monde
des festivités avec un point d'orgue à
la venue tant attendue du père noël ici
aujourd'hui les enfants sages est ce que
c'est vrai
on vient tous les ans sur le parvis pour
pourvoir le père noël je prends quand
même toujours un peu de temps pour venir
voir les gens dans les villes pour
pouvoir leur dire un petit bonjour pour
qu'ils soient tous contents de me voir
avant pour que je puisse leur dire aussi
de ne pas oublier de mettre leurs
lettres dans les boîtes afin que je
puisse leur à nous amener leurs cadeaux
des cadeaux que petits et grands
retrouveront pied du sapin le matin de
noël